Jennifer Aniston we had done Ferris
Bueller's Day Off with her she was
ferris's Sister right of course we did
it without John Hughes how stupid is
that do you get it you did a television
a TV show we did a TV show right and and
we love we love Jennifer Aniston we did
some Pilots they were horrible wow then
I have the moment with her Sunset
Boulevard late at night Chevron gas
station we're filling up and she says
will it ever happen for me and I said
God I wanted to right and I meant that
because you saw her as a potential I saw
the star power I thought okay this can
work finally we have the friend script
right she's in a deal now it's CBS oh my
God Les puts her in a show called
muddling through right so we looked
everywhere else we wanted someone else
to be in that role because we couldn't
have Jennifer in first position and
finally we just said you know what we'll
take her in second position we'll take
the risk problem is we did do the pilot
muddling through go is going to Series
yeah so we are sharing Jennifer Aniston
Warner Brothers looks at me and they say
if you make episodes of friends you're
paying for them if we have to reshoot
the episodes without Jennifer because we
don't own the rights to Jennifer we're
not in first position wow and I just
said you know what we're doing it wow so
you could have had you you might have
had to slap all of the Friends episodes
if muddled through didn't get canceled
through we made six episodes of friends
we have a couple million dollars a piece
and business Affairs looks at me and
they go you're out of your mind because
you don't have the rights to use her I
said Les moonves had the rights to her
yeah how did you convince Les to let go
of her it was a bad show muddling
through was a bad show it was a really
bad show they put it on we scheduled
against it did Jennifer Aniston have to
go to let's move this and said please
she went to lesson she asked to be
released the answer was now ultimately
how did you get how did she get out of
her America voted America decided they
put muddling through on and it died and
my question was are they going to [__]
us by picking up a really bad show and
making more of them right right and the
answer was that didn't so once the show
was canceled she was free to do friends
that's the way it works and we had her
wow lucky for her can you imagine the
shake she must have gone through
thinking that man because you knew right
away she was doing double duty and you
knew that friends was going to be a big
hit right you felt it research sucked it
did yeah what didn't they like about it
they thought it was very narrow it was
Courtney Cox uh always in was she the
choice Courtney was uh always in
everyone loved Courtney the show was
written for that dude who played Ross
Schwimmer Schwimmer isn't that amazing
he was the big star early on he was the
first one to pop wow yeah and they wrote
it for him mostly they heard David
Schwimmer in their heads was David
Schwimmer that cast was unbelievably in
sync right they as as young kids out
there together and none of them had any
level of success it was all the
beginning but we believed that
television makes stars all he does and
Schwimmer was supposed to be the big
star and he probably could have asked
for more money than the rest of them in
the beginning but he wisely went to them
and said let's negotiate as a group
we'll all get the same thing yeah the
warden brothers and NBC went to the cast
and said hey let's get let's get more
years things are working this is all
good and uh Schwimmer said why don't we
all just be equals I don't want to go to
work and know that someone else has paid
more and Schwimmer could have been at
the high end if they had just and he
just as a network president are you like
oh [__] that swim is a big [__]
problem he's getting them all negotiated
at the same no actually you know the
feeling was I don't think they ever
would have done it for a decade together
if they didn't have that sense of
equality now ultimately that egalitarian
sensibility that David Schwimmer asked
them to embrace it ended up working
powerfully on their behalf as they
renegotiated contract after contract
foreign